quelle famille la vôtre la mienne peut
être demain jean louis gasset cette
maison m'inquiète pas vous alors avec le
walkman sur les oreilles ils ordinateur
à la maison on finit la vie de famille
non je crois que si vous voulez me dire
que l'ordinateur personnel va faire
concurrence à la télévision à la bière
pourquoi pas l'ordinateur personnel
c'est devenu un nouveau médium culturel
mais à la différence de la vidéo c'est
un médium actifs participatif et avec un
ordinateur personnel à la maison par
exemple on peut réfléchir on peut
s'éduquer parce que c'est fini l'époque
du diplôme valable pour toute la vie on
peut jouer et tout ça on peut le faire
tout seul avec l'ordinateur comme
parthenay nom qu'on peut le faire aussi
en famille à plusieurs dont je crois que
s'il ya bien un médium culturel qui va
plutôt donné des occasions d'une vie de
famille active
participatif je crois que c'est
l'ordinateur personnel alors
l'informatique dans la gestion
administrative c'est fait mais à la
maison quelle est son utilité
véritablement écouter d'abord il faut je
crois qu'il faut partir du principe que
effectivement c'est fini l'époque de
l'informatique pour techno prêtre
réservé une caste de gens qui savaient
les ordinateurs sont devenus
suffisamment malins pour qu'on puisse en
quelque sorte leur apprendre l'homme
donc l'ordinateur est devenu accessible
à tout le monde sans un sens un ticket
de passage coûteuse du point de vue
intellectuel
d'autre part de l'époque du travail
physique nous sommes passés au travail
intellectuel
ce qui fait que l'ordinateur personnel
ne connaît plus les frontières boulot
dodo et donc on va pouvoir comme au
bureau réfléchir communiquer ces idées à
dos puisque je si j'ai un ordinateur
personnes la maison je peux le brancher
dans la prise du téléphone et
communiquer en courrier électronique et
même en conversation par l'ordinateur
avec le monde entier
est-ce que c'est facile pour les plus de
40 ans d'utiliser cette nouvelle
technologie peut dire est ce qu'il ya
des des cours particuliers et est ce que
vraiment moi particulier enfin j'ai
l'impression assez difficile ah oui non
mais je veux
vous avez vous avez raison de poser la
question je vous donne un exemple mon
papa je lui donnais mon apple pour là
pour la fête des pères
il a 62 ans il n'avait jamais touché un
ordinateur j écoute moi je refuse de me
l'apprendre parce qu'il est difficile
d'apprendre à son papa je dis voilà il
ya un livre d'exercices et puis
l'ordinateur peut apprendre lui-même te
servir de lui et c'est devenu le héros
du quartier de tous les gamins de sa dé
sa classe d'âge et je crois que ça je
crois que ça prouve bien que
l'ordinateur n'est pas n'est pas si
méchant que ça et que ça peut
être au contraire une ouverture pour des
gens qui avaient effectivement la
crainte que dix ans après 40 ans je peux
plus apprendre grand chose je peux plus
retourner à l'école à l'ordinateur
ordinateur ça peut être aussi d'accueil
permanente alors brossé nous très vite
le tableau de l'an 2000 l'homme presse
bouton non non je crois pas que ce soit
l'homme presse bouton je crois que
l'ordinateur ça ça va être dans la rue
en 2000 la fusion de tous que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui l'ordinateur
comme une merveilleuse feuille de papier
crayon calculette électronique mais
aussi d'ordinateurs branchés sur une
encyclopédie avec les disques numériques
ça va être l'ordinateur branché dans les
télécommunications comme on le comme on
le connaît aujourd'hui et pour pour
communiquer avec le monde entier non
l'ordinateur ça va devenir de plus en
plus pour les travailleurs du savoir que
nous sommes maintenant ça va devenir en
quelque sorte lui et même de l'esprit
nous ouvrir des horizons et en l'an 2000
on aura des horizons encore plus vaste
grâce à l'ordinateur personnel attend
mieux le portrait de l'homme nouveau est
arrivé daniel mailhot dit c'est à vous m